kash patel is a former national security
adviser to the house intel committee he
joins us tonight to sort out what the
second part of this story means cash
bill thanks so much for coming on
tonight so how should we understand this
fine of the hillary clinton campaign
uh thanks tucker so the main thing to
take away is that the hillary clinton
campaign broke federal law that's why
they levied this fine when i was leading
the russiagate investigation we had to
get a subpoena from congress to get the
bank records to show that the hillary
clinton campaign and the dems paid for
the steele dossier and three years later
the fec finally woke up and said yes
that's illegal and we need to find them
had any other campaign done it they
would have fined them to the tune of
tens of millions of dollars but i'll
take this at the start but the biggest
takeaway is the hillary clinton campaign
broke federal law by taking political
contributions and paying a foreign asset
to gin up dirty russian information that
was fake that they funneled into the fbi
to falsely surveil uh president trump uh
under illegal warrants issued by the
federal uh surveillance court
so the whole thing was a scam it was
illegal they'd been fined for it it
wouldn't have worked unless the entire
washington press corps abetted it went
along with it reported this stuff as
true when it was fact it was just
another set of campaign lies it was oppo
has anybody apologized for their roles
in this
i don't think those 51 intel analysts
the heads of the cia they called hunter
biden's laptop russian did for
information have apologized they
actually doubled down and said they were
glad to give the warning even though
they've been proven wrong hillary
clinton and the steel team and fusion
gps have not apologized even though her
lawyers for the campaign have been
indicted by special counsel john durham
so federal indictments federal fines
showing uh corruption and a breaking of
the federal law is not enough for the
mainstream media to come around and say
not only did they get it wrong but they
got it so wrong that they need to be
calling out the hillary clinton campaign
and now probably joe biden or actually
his son hunter because these people have
been corrupting the media for decades
and they are supposed to be the bastion
the dynastic bastions of democratic uh
of the democratic party and they have
failed
in upholding the principles of the law
which we you and i have reported on for
so long well and they they prevented us
from having a free and fair election in
2020 by suppressing information voters
needed to know and the people who did
that those 51 former intel officials all
still have their security clearances
which they use to make millions they
trade on those clearances
why do they still have their security
clearances they don't work for the
government anymore they work for msnbc
they
that's a great point and it's not it's
not a law that they have them they are
it's a regulation and those can be
revoked immediately and they should be
revoked immediately because they were
spreading as former cabinet secretaries
lies about political operatives that
they favored one over the other and they
got an elect they got a presidential
candidate and joe biden to come out
during an election and say look three
cia directors a director of the nsa and
a secretary of defense said my son's
laptop is russian defense information so
so much of the american public believed
them and they were all lying and they
knew it because they didn't have access
to the intel then and um they don't have
it now and they should have their
security clearances revoked immediately
what happened all the civil libertarians
on the left it's it's down to like matt
taibbi and glenn greenwald and naomi
wolf and that's it
it's unbelievable category vanish more
quickly
cash patel i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight